Shortly after I published my book,
I got an email.
It said,
"Your book was the only thing
that saved me from suicide.
You saved my life."
Now, for a book about how to clean,
that's sort of odd, yeah?
(Laughter)
But what if a new approach to cleaning
could teach us a better approach
to treating mental health?
I'm not an interior designer
or a lifestyle influencer.
I'm just a therapist with ADHD.
And in February of 2020,
I had my second baby.
Because with the first one,
I had some postpartum anxiety
and my husband had just taken
a very demanding job
that was going to keep him busy,
I developed a meticulous
postpartum plan for myself.
My family would rotate in in shifts
for the first 60 days.
The cleaning crew would come once a month.
The new moms group would drop off dinners.
And my toddler would go to preschool.
I was so proud of this plan,
and it ended before it even began.
Because 2020 is when the COVID
lockdowns happened
and all of that support
disappeared overnight.
In a blur, my days turned
into breastfeeding difficulties,
toddler meltdowns and depression.
The dishes stayed in the sink for days.
The laundry pile
reached impressive heights.
And there was often not a path
to walk from room to room.
And when I should have been
catching up on sleep,
I would lay in bed at night
and think to myself,
"I'm failing.
Maybe I'm not capable
of being a good mom to two kids."
I decided to post a joke video
on TikTok one day
about my house-turned-disaster.
(Laughter)
Some funny shots
of my clutter and my dishes
and my enchilada pan to a nice beat.
Sort of a laugh to keep
from cry situation, surely.
And I got a comment.
"Lazy."
Yeah, that stung.
But I must be a glutton for punishment
because I kept posting videos
about my messy house.
(Laughter)
Video after video of all of the weird tips
and tricks that I was using
to try and get it back in order
while managing my feelings
of being overwhelmed.
And I braced myself for more criticism.
But what happened was entirely different.
In the comment sections of my videos,
hundreds of stories came rolling in.
Stories like Amanda,
who, after losing her baby
in the second trimester,
was standing frozen at her sink
because she forgot how to wash dishes.
Stories like Lula,
whose chronic health
problems and depression
made it difficult for her
to brush her teeth.
Story after story of people
with depression, ADHD,
autism, burnout, bereavement,
all struggling with these daily tasks.
And it might seem odd to some of you
that someone could struggle
with tasks that are so simple.
But are they simple?
Let's think about what really goes
into something like laundry.
Everyone picture your laundry
pile right now, OK?
How many clean clothes
do you have left right now?
Can you wash tomorrow,
or must it be today?
Do you need to prioritize,
presort pre-treat anything?
Did you grow up with anybody
that taught you how to do that?
You're out of laundry detergent,
if you work three jobs, when are you
going to get to the store next?
If you get there, can you afford it?
And if you can, which one you choose?
And you get it all home, get in there,
Now pick a setting. Which one?
I don't know. Google it.
By the way, you have memory problems,
so you'll remember that wash
in about three days,
when it's mildewed into the washer.
It's OK, just re-wash it,
and get it into the dryer.
You'll forget that too, and it'll wrinkle.
Now dry it again.
Now all you have to do
is get it out and fold it.
But also you have three small children.
And those three small children
haven't given you a moment alone
in quite some time.
When you finally get that moment,
you have to decide,
are you going to finish the laundry
or eat a sandwich or take a nap?
Time's up, you didn't do any of it,
you stared at the wall.
You have decision fatigue
because the burden of carrying a home
all by yourself has burnt you out.
You see, for some of you,
all of the steps and the skills
that go into care tasks run on autopilot.
But for millions of people,
the autopilot is broken.
And what's worse, what if you had to do
all of that when your mom just died
or your job just fired you
or you’re using every ounce
of strength that you have
to just not kill yourself today?
If you have access to therapy,
it's unlikely your therapist
will ever ask you about your laundry.
I've worked in mental health
for about a decade.
I've been in therapy even longer,
and the only time I ever had
a provider talk to me
about things like cooking and cleaning
and brushing my teeth
was when I was in a psych
hospital as a teenager.
Yet here were hundreds
of thousands of people
in my comment sections telling me
that these daily care tasks
were a major pain point in their life.
And so I started to wonder,
what if we started here?
What if we started with these care tasks?
Could making daily tasks easier
improve mental health quicker?
In the two years that I've been
posting and writing
about the intersection
of mental health and care tasks,
I've come up with a philosophy
that does just this.
And it all starts with one simple idea.
Cooking, cleaning, laundry,
it doesn't make you a good person.
Or a bad person.
Listen to me.
Care tasks are morally neutral.
Now, I know that if you've been watching
Martha Stewart for decades --
(Laughter)
and scrolling the perfect
Pinterest aesthetic every day,
that it can feel like struggling
with these tasks is a moral failure.
Like, it's because we're lazy
or irresponsible or we're immature.
But having an organized closet
doesn't make you a success.
And living out of a pile of laundry
on the floor doesn't make you a failure.
You know where the shirt
you want to wear is, it just ...
(Laughter)
It might take you
a bit of sifting to find it.
(Laughter)
The truth is, it's not about morality.
It's about functionality.
Does your home work for you?
Not some hypothetical houseguest
that is coming to inspect your closet.
(Laughter)
I mentioned Amanda, who had lost her baby
and forgot how to wash dishes.
She told me that when
her husband would go to work,
she would lay on the floor
next to the empty crib
and say to herself,
"What can I bring to my family
if I can't even wash dishes?"
But that changed
when she began to see
care tasks as morally neutral.
All of the sudden, the dishes in the sink
weren't representations
of her failure as a wife,
but instead she would look at the pile
and think to herself, "What do I need
to function tomorrow morning?"
And then pull two coffee cups
out of the pile to wash.
She had her coffee the next morning,
and it was a little bit easier
to get up off the floor.
When we liberate ourselves from the idea
that we are a good person or a bad person
with care tasks,
we can stop thinking
about the right way to do things.
About the way that things should be done,
and instead start thinking
about what we can do
with our current barriers
to improve our quality of life today.
And this is the fun part.
Because you get to customize a life
that works for you.
When Lula realized that her problems
with brushing her teeth
were not moral failings,
she gained the confidence to speak
to her dental hygienist,
and together they came up with solutions
that work around her barriers.
She now relies on pre-pasted
disposable toothbrushes
that she keeps in her desk,
floss she keeps in the living room
and a no-rinse prescription toothpaste.
Because by breaking down the component
parts of a dental hygiene routine
and ensuring that each step was accessible
to her mental and physical needs,
for the first time in a year,
she's done every step in that routine
for two weeks straight.
She says that now
that her teeth are clean,
she's a little less stressed
about tomorrow's problems.
And this approach can work
with any care task
that you struggle with.
Simply ask yourself,
"What am I trying to achieve
and how can I achieve it in my way?"
In a rare moment of folding clothes ...
(Laughter)
I looked down at the baby onesie
that I was folding,
and I thought to myself,
"Why am I folding this?"
(Laughter)
Baby onesies don't really wrinkle.
And even if they did, nobody cares
if a baby's in a wrinkly onesie.
(Laughter)
Furthermore, I was probably
going to change her
four times before lunch.
(Laughter)
This doesn't need to be folded.
I said it out loud
and literally braced myself
for the laundry police?
I don't know.
There are rules to laundry.
But for the first time,
I stopped thinking about the way
that laundry should be done.
And instead, started thinking
about how I could make
laundry functional for me.
And I looked down at the fleece pajamas
and the underwear and the athletic shorts
and the tank tops
and realized almost none of my clothes
actually needed to be folded.
And I haven't folded any of it since.
(Cheers and applause)
I moved all of my family's clothes
into one closet off the laundry room,
and now I just toss things
into organized bins unfolded.
(Cheers and applause)
My new motto is: “Good enough is perfect.”
(Laughter and applause)
And everything worth doing
is worth doing half-assed.
(Laughter and applause)
You have to give yourself
permission to do a little.
To do it with shortcuts.
To do it while breaking all of the rules.
And replace that inner voice that says,
“I’m failing,”
with one that says, "I'm having
a hard time right now.
And people who are having a hard time
deserve compassion."
If it's too hard to shower today,
grab the baby wipes.
It may not be the normal way to do it,
but you deserve to be clean.
If it's too hard to cook dinner,
get paper plates,
heat up something frozen.
You’ll go back to cooking
and washing another day,
but the day is not today.
And in the meantime,
you deserve to eat.
If you're too depressed to do your dishes,
get a two-gallon Ziploc bag
and keep it in your bedroom.
Because if you put a dirty plate
into a two-gallon Ziploc bag and seal it,
it will keep the bugs away.
And it'll be there for you
when you're ready
to go back to the kitchen.
Because you deserve
a sanitary environment
even if you can't get out of bed.
I could share with you
hundreds of other genius solutions
that people have come up with
once they embraced the idea
that care tasks are morally neutral.
In my experience, people will exhibit
mind-blowing creativity
when they are only taught
how to speak compassionately
to themselves.
So what if mental health
treatment started here?
By shifting the idea of care tasks
as these external measurements
of your worthiness
to just being morally-neutral tasks
that you can customize
to care for yourself.
Because if it's true
that regardless of what you struggle with,
you are worthy of a functional space,
what else might you be worthy of?
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)